♪ ♪ ♪
- Tout près du Parlement,
mais loin des regards...
(sifflements)
... la simple citoyenne
Catherine McKenna prend
le temps de souffler.
La vie n'est plus la même
pour cette ancienne ministre
libérale qui a fait ses adieux
à la politique.
CATHERINE McKENNA, ancienne
ministre fed. de l'Environnement
et de l'Infrastructure
- J'ai l'air heureux,
tout le monde me dit toujours
que j'ai l'air heureux!
- Ses années tumultueuses comme
ministre de l'Environnement
semblent déjà loin derrière,
même si elles ont laissé
des traces.
- J'ai très vite compris
qu'il y a des gens qui
voulaient utiliser que
j'étais femme contre moi.
- Femme et ministre, elle est
devenue la cible des opposants
au prix sur le carbone,
exposée au harcèlement
et aux attaques constantes.
Même du personnel politique de
son propre parti lui reprochait
de laisser trop de place
à ses émotions.
- J'ai eu un message
qui m'a dit : "Calmez-vous."
Calme-toi? Non, je ne vais pas
me calmer.
- Une autre preuve, selon elle,
du traitement inégal réservé
aux femmes en politique.
- Si on est trop émotionnelle,
on est une femme, on n'est pas
assez forte, alors on peut pas
gagner.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Alors que Catherine McKenna
cherche à défendre la cause
climatique autrement,
hors de la politique,
d'autres ministres quittent leur
fonctions, mais pas par choix.
Le nom de Deb Schulte
disparaîtra bientôt de
son bureau de circonscription
de King-Vaughan en Ontario.
La ministre sortante des Aînés
a perdu son élection par
1000 voix. Elle partage
l'amertume de la défaite
avec deux autres collègues
du Cabinet qui ont aussi mordu
la poussière, Maryam Monsef
et Bernadette Jordan.
La transition est difficile
pour les ministres défaites,
surtout que Deb Schulte
se bat contre un cancer.
Mais elle ne regrette rien
de son passage aux Communes
et au Cabinet.
Elle s'est sentie écoutée
par Justin Trudeau autour
de la table du Conseil
des ministres, spécialement
quand elle parlait de
la précarité des femmes aînées.
Une attention qui tranche
avec son passage dans le privé
quelques années plus tôt,
comme cadre au sein de
l'entreprise Bombardier.
Souvent la seule femme
aux tables décisionnelles,
c'était très difficile d'être
entendue, raconte-t-elle.
♪ ♪ ♪
Au Parlement, les femmes sont
toujours sous-représentées.
Elles ne composent que
le tiers des députés.
Justin Trudeau a déjà promis
que son prochain Conseil des
ministres sera encore paritaire,
un critère encore perçu
par trop de gens comme
étant symbolique, déplore
Catherine McKenna.
- Non, nous ne sommes pas
des trophées. Oui, il y a
des considérations quand
on fait un Cabinet, c'est sûr,
mais nous sommes...
les femmes, nous sommes 50 %
de la population.
- C'est dans cet édifice anonyme
du centre-ville d'Ottawa
que l'équipe de transition
de Justin Trudeau essaie
de former le Cabinet idéal;
représentation régionale,
diversité culturelle
et parité des genres.
Quatre femmes de son ancienne
équipe ministérielle ne seront
pas de retour au Parlement.
Il faut doncrouver les bonnes
candidates pour les bons postes.
PASCALE ST-ONGE, députée, PLC
Brome-Missisquoi, Qc
- La politique, comme
bien d'autres secteurs,
a longtemps été un boys club.
Je suis contente que vous soyez
dans la région!
(rire)
- Parmi les nouvelles élues,
des noms circulent, comme celui
de l'ancienne leader syndicale
Pascale St-Onge. Elle fait
la tournée des commerces locaux
pour rencontrer ses électeurs.
À peine élue, elle demeure
prudente lorsqu'on évoque
la possibilité qu'elle soit
nommée ministre.
- La raison principale
pour laquelle je me suis lancée
en politique, c'était
pour représenter les gens
de Brome-Missisquoi.
- Selon elle, la diversité
autour de la table
des précédents cabinets
a donné des résultats.
- Par exemple, le programme pour
les garderies, il y a des femmes
autour de la table qui ont
poussé ce genre de dossier là.
- À ses yeux, d'autres voix
gagnent aussi à être mieux
entendues pour avoir
un portrait plus représentatif
de la société.
- Je pense aussi que les
personnes trans, entre autres,
présentement, vivent encore
beaucoup ces préjugés-là.
Il y a encore de la violence
à l'endroit de la communauté
LGBTQ2+.
- Femme de la communauté gaie et
syndicaliste du milieu culturel,
elle arrive à Ottawa avec
un  bagage qui est le sien.
- J'ai hâte de découvrir
tout ça, mais le rôle en soi
donne un peu le vertige.
- L'une arrive et l'autre
quitte. Impossible de
transmettre l'expérience,
mais l'ancienne ministre
se permet un conseil.
- Soyez-vous même.
C'est difficile, tous les gens
vont vous dire comment
vous devez vous habiller,
regarder, parler.
Ils vont vous conseiller
comment faire les décisions.
- Rester fidèle à ses valeurs,
malgré la rudesse de
l'aventure politique.